first and foremost congratulations first
time nominee first time winner how does
it feel
it feels so much better than you think
it feels you know it's like when I heard
them say my name it wasn't that I didn't
believe it but I didn't believe it and I
was like it was like you know an echo
Shirley Rob Shirley then I was like
that's me they call My Name They Call My
Name
I couldn't move you could move and you
had to cast walk you to Stage they
brought you up there and then you graced
us you let out this beautiful song and
just sent the world reeling talk to me
what was going on in your mind I just
was so damn beautiful thank you you know
this has not been easy yeah
and to be in an industry that I love
it has been difficult at times
but to have
them say that I'm the one of the best of
the best
and then that group of women wow they're
pretty blessed good
and to get this in my hand
god and goddess are so wonderful and I'm
so happy that I'm right here at this
time and able to say Abbott Elementary
your new favorite TV show and I play
Barbara Howard and you're gonna love it
yeah
facts big facts I want to talk about
your support system in Jamaica having a
viewing party for you and you're going
to be the honorable title when you go
back talk to me about this
we have something called Heroes weekend
and people who have done exemplary
things who have made a difference in the
world in the country in the community
are acknowledged and I was chosen for
one of the how highest honors and that
is order of Jamaica it's very much like
the Medal of Honor that Denzel received
the difference is though that my name
will change I will now be known as The
Honorable Cheryl Lee Ralph comma OJ
order of Jamaica I wonder if that means
I have to wave like this yes you do
thank you my godfather past prime
minister
moment I love you thank God congrats
thank you
thank you thank you so much goodness the
honor The Honorable PJ Patterson as soon
as it happened his texts came right
through and he said my niece I couldn't
be happier he said come home bring the
trophy we're ready to welcome you oh my
goodness a powerful night for Abbott
Elementary my goodness let's talk about
Quinta for a second she's got this
comedy writing and me I mean just speak
on it you guys are repping so hard let
me tell you something I tell everybody
my boss is half my age and I love her
you talk about intergenerational I
always tell everybody all of my children
succeed and my TV child the teacher in
Janine oh she's going to do quite well
you are powerful thank you thank you
I'll let you run out of here but we're
going to talk about the good your show's
doing real quick the fyc money is going
to Public Schools talk to me about how
important that is you're not just a
great show you're also doing something
and backing it up you know know
something my husband is a senator in
Pennsylvania Senator Vincent Hughes and
he represents the area that
Abbott Elementary would be in and he's
been fighting for Education all the
years that he's been office and for me
to be in a show like this to match our
spirits up to make and raise money and
shine focus on education to let people
know teachers are not the butt of the
joke they are the heart of the whole
program a lot of this is for the
Educators across this country and the
world who are making a difference in
America every day and they deserve more
if I could get you all more money I
would
you are so powerful congratulations to
You Dare I ask you to sing a piece of
that thing you sang on stage and moved
us all right now
I am an endangered species but I sing No
victim song I am a woman I am an artist
and I know where my voice
belongs I'm going to Disneyland and
Jamaica come on I feel like I won
tonight just being in your presence
congratulations you are absolute gold if
there's something better than gold
you're better than that I promise my
honor speaking with you tonight thank
you thank you
[Music]
foreign